Welcome everyone, today we have a very very special video and we're here with Thomas Brush.
Hello. Hello. Thomas, what have you been up to the last two weeks?
Um, well, you kind of forced me to make a game for you. What?!
Yeah.
So you forced, yeah dude, you forced me to make a game for you.
So, I didn't eat or sleep for 14 days. You have not left the dungeon. Haven't left the dungeon, um dude
It's weird cuz like, me and my wife are sort of displaced. We're building a house right now
So I actually work in my parents basement. Oh, there you go. I'm literally right now at 7:00 a.m
at least my time, in my parents basement and this is where I've been working for 14 days because you
Uh, you made me make a game for you. So it's all your fault
Okay, I feel like you're putting a little bit too much of me there, ok
So, for those who you don't know. Maybe you should explain so I dared PewDiePie to dare me to
Make a game in 14 days for him
Um, and so he said yes in the latest LWIAY?
I did say yes, that's right. (I think that's when you said yes...)
And uh, then I was like, oh crap. I actually have to do this
(Pew laugh) So, we did it. I'm really looking forward to play this (well thanks, man) should we jump into it?
Yeah, whenever you're ready. A game by Thomas Brush- that's you! That's me, that's me.
Sponsored by gamers for good. My name is Thomas Brush, I am the creator of this game
I actually made this game in about 14 days and this is working
Subscribe to either one if they're already subscribed subscribe to me. We've linked everybody
I like this
This is so cool. By the way. Thank you. I mean it was the best
It was literally probably the best idea for the game. They wanted to see you doing that the little tv meme
:O
i didn't get it, of coursee!
oh, that's great!
Alright, should i start it?
Yeah, let's go. I'm ready. It's crazy you did this in 2 weeks. Oh, I did voice acting!
That's right. You did
it doesn't matter
So I mean the voice acting is 10 out of 10. Oh for sure. I love it
At least I have my wife
And it's me in the closet, that's great
Oh, no, that's not a lot of subscribers
Yeah, so this is this is the apocalypse Felix, this is what the apocalypse looks like
The cutscene artwork was done by gamers for good. That's why they're the sponsor
It's actually a former Blizzard concept artist is running that and so he he actually livestream the creation
Oh
Dad
This is crazy. Oh look at this is just how I started my videos
Dude I won that punitive sign that's so sick. Yeah. This book loves you. Oh, I love Petersons reference
I see right good catch. I was wondering if you would see that
Let's say this origin set up. My beautiful origin Senate haven't touched these things since 2019
Examine the sub dad ha ha ha
This is very accurate
Exactly this is sick like
The style is so cool. I appreciate it. you get this.. Yeah. Oh hell. Yeah
So I think this is actually the only thing I added which was like you should collect
Yeah. No, I mean dude when you showed up in the chat the live stream chat on the first day
It was such a relief and you
Because I didn't know with you even cared about the project to be like eh
You just said yeah sure make a game in like it was so cool. Cuz everyone was like
Holy crap pewdiepie is right here in the chat
Mr. Beast is in it. yeah. No, I'm totally glad like I'm just happy you did this like spent two weeks. Yeah. All right
Look, I want to play that. Mr. Beast wondering when you would show up. Yeah
So wait, did you get Mr. Beast to do the lines or is it me? No, okay. Oh
Hey we made dad happy
I don't know if you know where that's from, but that's actually when he donated to you
oh you took it from a video! yea ok ok
AHHHAHAH
oh, no ;<
Oh that makes sense and every meme is dead
I am freaking out. why wouldn't 'I?
oh, no! :0
Is fornite still a thing?, I like this.
What could my secret weapon be Thomas? You have to find out
So how would you recommend playing like with jumping on space is kinda uhh
um.. What? what do you mean?
With punching or whatever. Brighton UK. Never mind, okay
Can I double jump? How do I get this Thomas? you got to-This is why I'm really glad you're on-
I need help playing video games. How about you just play the game like a normal person.
Like the T reference on that. yeah, damn
It's tight, man. okay. I'm going to I'm going for the
The brofist symbol it has to be mine. Alright, let's read this
aww ;3
:0
That's nice tho. yeah, that was that was your audience dude they just in the livestream they just like we're
sort of talking about how they wanted to include him and give him that Ruby of honor. you know
that's dope
Okay, so how am I doing so far? dude, you're amazing.
but I'm not surprised. oh, thank you. when you're playing as urself
*hes mumbling :c*
You're playing as yourself, so I expect you're gonna be good
Okay, thank you. well it would be embarrassing if I was bad yet.
Are you kidding me??
nevermind, you kinda suck.
ThIS GaMe SucK! okay :[
That's so cool. Oh that's AI epic I
Did not expect Ben Shapiro in this game. Oh, hey Felix, I want to buy back your super awesome chair
so why am I buying my chair from Ben Shapiro you
Wouldn't happen to have three ninety-nine month I station coins on you. Oh, so that's why I collected those. That's smart
Okay, let me go find some coins
Why'd you steal my chairman Shapiro?
Did he say this yet in your meme review? Oh
He did of course. Yeah. Oh my god. I'm so out of it. Well, it was so hard to find something that was relevant
No, I was perfect
But obviously I does need some money to buy a life insurance policy
For when I plotz tombs at the NIEM cemetery are kind of pricey
Thanks Ben Shapiro. Give me back my chair. I want it
All right what we got here check one cabinet. Oh
This is so fun, I appreciate it dude, I love this. I was hoping you'd like it I harvest what is this
How could you oh, okay. That's fine I get monetization from that. Yeah. That's all that matters. Okay
Arrest the signpost read to meme cemetery. All right, we know where we going
I'm really glad I didn't cheat and like look too much. I didn't know what to get you sitting like I did already
No, of course, I'm I want to save it
Yeah, but like I am familiar with your work obviously and yeah, I know that quality you put into it. So I
Expected it to be kids, but I didn't expect it to be this College like 10 weeks. Well, thanks. Thanks. There we go
Here's the 3:19 chair perform an epic 399 smash attack. Just hold down while jumping and attacking
Who knows might help you get you the meme cemetery? So what what side what is a hold poke down while I go?
Oh, yeah
Yeah
That's awesome. We know of course of Coriana you do that your spirits up. Yeah, this is our
I had no idea what I was talking
This is a great voice reverberating that's our word that I use in my mind actually not strong
They took a step
Into the meme cemetery. Oh
God, oh god, Thomas
No, you like it dark, but this is just too much
Okay things you got to start getting intense Felix, oh oh
Oh
Don't you worry about it? I figured the barrels were a good place to be in like in the meme cemetery
Of course and you got a nut goes where he belongs?
yeah, so it was really tough figuring out which needs to include in the mean cemetery because I mean there's like
hundreds of thousands and so
We sort of everyone in that I raised. Yeah, they want everything
We they sort of voted on them on the subreddit now, of course nice. Oh
It's so it's such a bizarre experience playing a game like based on you, but it's so sure
You're gonna knuckles a tombstone
You got a knuckles for January 2018 died July 2018 cause of death unknown
Okay, sure. Hahaha. Oh god, they're flying now
Rest in peace you've gotten enough goals
Oh God, it is getting intense you're not joking hey
Is there another button to punish instead of miles
no, and I've had requests for that, but I figured I
Think maybe you'll get used to it
Okay, I feel like but okay, but by the way, you see you jump in space for you some loot
Yeah, okay. You got it you jump with space and maybe I need to change it. Yeah, I'll do whatever you want me to
You did this in two weeks, I think it's all right, I
Can't blame my bad skills on you sleepy no
Let's see what he has to say a tombstone would sleep me. It's trying to save something. Hey buddy. I miss you so much
I doubt it
I was in it was he credible glowing alongside you in your career, though
The thick and through the significance said I was and I am there for you
Dude
My feels well, will you find your love and bring it to me sometimes?
I wonder if you've forgotten about your love for me. Never
I'll never forget about you. Say I like here. You have it Felix
I'll remember you saying that always now go find your love and bring it back to me who always my love
It's got to be
monetization and not Mars
Poor vessel at risk on very nice a beloved Borba
So 600 to 500 BC for June 2018 Dino destroyed 18 cause of death
because boring
Yeah, again all these means were straight up from neurotic good mean yeah, oh really yeah, dude I didn't I wouldn't know ah
Really lucky you're utilizing glitch. What do you mean lucky? You're cute Eliza glitches to your advantage snow glitch. Well, that's
It's the developer put it in there. Oh
This is the worst game I have ever played come here, buddy
Nice hell, yeah
I've got Oh God
We'll get him. They're ready. I think you're figuring it out. Oh, I
Love this attack. It feels so good
G-Fuel!! oh, oh
no,you're good you're good
This is intense man. there is a checkpoint and I think there's like 2 G-fuels coming up. So just be careful
Yeah, I don't wanna mess up now
There's the G-fuel go. I'm gonna deal with this guy first. Oh, there's a lot of G-fuel
You got one health left there you go. Yeah you don't worry
Easy? Oh god. I got one health left again. Oh, thank god
Okay
Okay, no checkpoint. I like that. It's a bit challenging then. How do I play with three hands spared? What the hell?
Why did you put it over? Are you not playing with three hands? I'm playing with three hands
Okay
Where's my G-fuel? Oh it's not Oh God. Yeah, you're screwed. I like this Thomas
Yeah, I like this. That's Big Chungus! Maybe let's just end the stream here and just pretend that you're you're amazing. Yeah
We don't need to pretend just watch this
DAMMIT! >:0
Anytime you see a missile Felix you can do that chair attack and it won't hurt you. So it's kind of cheat but uhh
All right, or I can do that you can do that oh
Thank god that last one had G-fuel nice
That is hot. born April 2018 died October 2018 cause of death deep fried out of existence
Thomas I just realized I haven't been playing with wasd I've been playing with the air. Oh, please so that's why you suck I
Was like, why would you put three having three hands to play this game? That's what I was wondering like what?
Three hands, you have to realize hey, this is why I should stress test games because I play like all the idiots. I
Don't know why I used to have maybe
Is that standard? i don't- oh, this is so much better. Well, I'm actually surprised you did so well
like jumping from the keyboard to the space
Okay, so you guys- oh, I have an extra live now? No you got Slippy's heart.
you got- well you found your love and now that was an idea of one of your uhh- he said
Just give slippy a gemstone heart and I thought that that was the most beautiful thing you can give to slippy
Here you go slippy may you rest in peace Oh Felix you found your love for me please place it in my hand
So I can hold it forever because of your love. I will always show up
Okay, well now I know how to actually play the games I think I'll be all right
I'm not sure told you that I just so this is a Donkey Kong Country reference. I mean
It's really a you reference cause you like barrel
But it does kind of look like Donkey Kong
You know like the spinning barrel, so you jump into it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, but you can actually punch it
So, oh I see why I was confused about the controls because I was clicking out of the game
i can't move. I'm still- that's why I thought I had to use- dude. I'm so surprised. You got this far
Oh sLIPPYY!!
Felix I love you so much. I told you I'd show up
when u need me. bounce on my head now to enjoy life to fly high. thank you slippy.
:O
Hell yeah
thanks sleepy and by the way Felix, you can't break that that barrel of
Get that I want it. Okay, but you have to kind of get on that roof. Oh
Hell yeah, oh
All the monetization points. You deserve Felix. Ah
Thanks, man
Big chunga's for December 2018 died February 2019 cuz of death murdered by Karen, Chungas
That's f-ing Karen. Goose Wayne is in the game! look at that. Okay a tombstone
okay why
oh shi- Goose! you forgot your mask!
That's great that's so fun. I can't believe you made this in two weeks
Well fourteen days and I cheated a little bit I threw in a couple extra days
well, regardless,
Oh You got Phill!! well- you got Phill man! wow, thanks, man! Oh, that's awesome
Thank you. Thank you. Dr. Phill.
I stole his lines from YouTube videos
You know
Thanks, dr. Bill. Thank you so much
Would you like to go or get the treatment Oh to go get the treatment
So I just it's just a quick trip on this rocket your long lent it to me Wow Ilan
Thank you for such an occasion. It's reusable and runs on CBD oil Wow
We've got a brand new state-of-the-art
Rancho Mirage, it'd be helpful. Where youtuber suffering from PTSD after the sub but uprising
Oh, and it's also been particularly helpful
to their subscribers as well ages nine and
So what do you say Felix come get treatment at the ranch?
It only costs 600 monetization points now get in that rocket at a crisis arranger. Oh
Yeah, I like how are you in the rocket is silently already I was lonely now
300 days aboard that cold and grant rocket
Felt like a lifetime
Supply for running there. I was scared. I was very sad. I would hungry I
Was even tempted to eat one of my leg
Whoa, I love it beware
psychotics psychotic nine-year-olds memory loyalty to fugitive peopie has led to psychosis and
self-mutilation of the legs
Wait a minute
My god the nine-year-old they don't have legs
What do you think oh
My god are those cows
What is happening back there? Tell us what is happening right there?
So part of the reason dude why the nine year olds don't have legs
I mean obviously it's a story telling it but the main reason is because I was running really low on time, hahaha
And so animating legs is like one of the hardest things to do. Oh, really?
For me at least like your character. Well, it took forever to animate. It looks like the running say nice
but I didn't want to have to do it for the 9 year olds like
It is
it's
So should I go to the right first or should I go up here?
Did you talk to the rover? No, I'll do that then go talk. Yeah, go talk to the robot
can can you please get me my
Bleep bleep. Oh
battery's
About this yeah, what was cool about this is I I had no idea what I wanted to do
I just knew I needed to block the player from getting to the right of the screen
Ah, so you're on your audience said hey put the Mars rover and then right next to it to block it put the Tesla. Oh
oh, yeah, and so it crash-landed into Mars because it's that whatever Oh
The Roadster, yeah, that's great. How do I get up there? So they bake there we go
Occupy Mars is that Elon? ELON!!!, hi felix
Have you seen this
Is he looking at meme? it's a dead dolphin
Anyways, would you buy my flamethrower for just one month this Asian coin?
Well, actually it's not really a flamethrower if it was it would cost 1 million monetization points
So I'm giving you a steal. Okay, I'll take it now
Should have a so why he lives there damn it
Well the way the reason is dr. Phil man, he just stranded him there and stole his rocket
But you right you right click Felix shoot the flamethrower
I'll be careful you go run out. Sorry
This is a deer. Yeah, dude. It's the dolphin. I mean a dolphin of course. Oh
Wait, so I need the battery. I got the batteries
Yep. Oh, I see. It is definitely the Tesla I like that
Thank you. That feels better. Wait. I think you put them in wrong
I
Could hear their this. Okay good you get saved. Now you're doing good. Yeah
Yeah, dude, I didn't expect the reasons long. Should I use the flamethrower these?
Yeah, I mean fuck it's what everyone let's just talk to Edgar when you can. All right, let's talk tiger. It's okay Oh
Rarely tells me the sub bus locked me in here
They sent my ransom for one thousand monetization coins
Okay, Edgar, haha
Enjoy your time in there and yeah, you're gonna stay there. Oh,
God, it's the last stand buddy. God. Damn. You went all out of it Oh
triple kill, baby
Nice
Okay, I'm gonna have five hundred wait sigh I mean a lot more
You'll find him I I added some really big ones that you can select okay, you'll be good by nine-year-old
Those nine year olds a bite you in the butt
in the back
Well goddamn look at this
Dude seriously before this fall I literally made a bill that's delete like makes the boss like half is easy
Oh just in case just in case
You can't you can't beat it and we'll play that- come on Thomas
What are you thinking me? There? It is a thousand Edgar. Ah
You fell for it. What?
Give me those going ever since he got so famous. You never gave me attention
so I made sure your little friends Jack Mark and
Marcia and Brad came with me and now we're gonna make sure everyone pays
Edgar hey Alex I got
No
Fun facts here shilling. Yes. That's my boy. I was just about to ask. That's great
Edgar okay
Get down here
Okay
All right. What do I do Thomas?
It beeped. Well, you just configure what which what do you think Edgar would do trying people EPIRBs somewhere? Oh
My god stop it, I got bad dog. What does he do?
Oh, I see Oh God
Come on oh
Yeah, I say it was that that was Jack oh, okay. Sorry I Jack you're gonna have to stay there for a while
And
That was my voice as well really I'm trying to be Marcia that was beautiful
Okay, so alive
You're doing good. Just two more. I like how they're just they're dangling
Showing up their legs
I'm surprised
And I think that's smart
So what about yes gone up
And the G-fuel I'll take it, i'll take it
You can't come up- OHH THEY CAN!! AHAHHA
you got this
oh god I should go for the-
oh dude, Holy crap. you gonna beat it on ur first try!
FIRST TRY BABYY!!
HOLY SHI-
HELL YEAA
you just beat it on your first try
AACK
oh. *just realise it's just edgar*
EDGAR!!
that's so cute uwu
felix aww
I'm so sorry for causing an apocalypse
No you weren't a bad dog
Please forgive me this might be a terrible segue... but... this nuke is about to blow...
Can you help me get out of here?
Oh, wow. great acting
As for me, I'm just glad I could see them one last time Oh glad I could say goodbye
How was it? The nine-year-olds used to call me. Yeah, that's right
PEWDIEpie.
my name
is PewDiePie
(>w<)
Thomas you killed it. amazing job.
They have of course by man, no they made they made this thing and they did a good job
I'll link to the game. You guys can download it. Check it out and support Thomas
Yeah, if you want to support you can leave a tip on the HIO page. It's a free game
So feel free to download it for free
I'd love you to play it and if you want to subscribe to PewDiePie's channel
Please do and if you already have subscribed to PewDiePie subscribe to my channel, I do live streaming every day
Thanks guys for watching. Guess that's a
Bye, bye. Alright. Thanks guys. Bye